this one is all about how everything
that's enjoyable is bad for your health
I am Nikolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Joe Jackson the
musician and the anti-smoking fan
activist hello thanks for talking to us
all right
you obviously feel really strongly about
anti-smoking laws what possessed you to
write a few years ago such a
meticulously annotated and thought
through manifesto against smoking bans I
think it shows that governments are
blurring the line between what's a
public space in the private space you
know they're very often talk about with
banning smoking in public places but it
seems to me that a public place is
something that's supported by public
money you know a public library or more
court or police station or something
those are public places a bar is clearly
not a public place it's private property
it's private business is it right for
the government to say you know what
smoking is bad for you so you should not
be allowed to do it or should that be an
individual choice the obvious sort of
elephant in the room there is the fact
that smoking is actually legal rosa
backhoe is legal basically a smoking ban
in bars for instance is saying that
adult citizens are not allowed to use a
legal substance even though they're very
highly taxed for doing so in a place
which is actually private property so
you're throwing out the window the
property rights of the owner of that
establishment freedom of choice you know
a lot of things compared to a health
risk which is really unproven well when
you say a health risk is unproven not
that cigarettes cause cancer but that
you can get cancer from secondhand smoke
the anti-smoking lobby has been trying
to fur for about 40 years to prove
this and they've not done so there's not
one proven documented case proven to be
caused by so-called secondhand smoke and
I've been looking for one for 10 years
so a lot of other people how can I ask
you know I agree with you and I have
colleagues who've written extensively on
this but why should we believe you or
who are you yeah I know how do we go
through the medical literature it's why
I don't do these interviews and the only
reason I'm here is because it's Reason
magazine and I hope that some amount of
reason comes into it somewhere but I'm
sick and tired of talking about this
because that's what I hear every time
yeah why should we believe you I'm not
asking you to believe me I mean you were
the media go do the research instead of
talking to me talk to an anti-smoking
representative of you know whatever
health organization ask them to explain
how they know that secondhand smoke
killed someone and produce the proof is
the smoking ban issue dead though I mean
we're sitting in a hotel room in New
York where in 2003 they ban smoking in
bars and restaurants earlier this year
they ban smoking outdoors basically is
is it a dead issue and if so you know
what do we do about it
or is there anything left to do yeah
well I don't believe it's a dead issue a
lot of people would like like us to
believe that of course the same as they
would would like us to believe that
alcohol prohibition was a dead issue in
about 1925
you know and that lasted for 13 years
but the fact is that smoking is still
legal everywhere in the world except for
the kingdom of Bhutan where the King
doesn't like it but they're very happy
they're writers I suppose about yes but
they have a huge problem with tobacco
smuggling right there's well over a
billion people in the world still smoke
and there is plenty of countries in the
world where you can still smoke in bars
what are the arguments that will
convince people to say hey you know what
it's not your business what I'm eating
when I'm drinking whether I exercise or
not it's going to take more people
having their own lifestyles and their
own choices affected I mean I think
there's a sort of gathering storm of
prohibitionism
you can see it more clearly in the UK
actually I think which is becoming very
much in 90 state these days but alcohol
prohibition ism is really on the right
and a lot of times the same people there
networking than the anti-tobacco people
to say how you know how have you been so
fantastically successful and it's going
to get worse and worse and I think it
probably needs to get worse before
people start to fight back you are not
in the employee of a tobacco company no
no okay there's the nanny I don't know
nothing to do the tobacco industry I
have no ax to grind
moving to music your jumpin jivin was
punked up swing R&B standard it was a
major departure from your kind of
earlier a style of new wave that you
were putting out in the late 70s and 80s
do you think a popular artist today
would it be as easy for them to convince
a record label to allow a major artist
to make that kind of shift away from
their signature sound definitely not but
then again they've not that many major
labels left and you know what what's
coming out on major labels is extremely
predictable you're based in Berlin now
and you at one point you were tributed
some of your impetus to move to Berlin
it was really to get out of Mike
Bloomberg's New York I mean what
attracts you about Berlin let's put it
that way it wasn't just Mike Bloomberg's
in Europe but but the UK as well I mean
I tried living back in the UK for a
while and realized that it was becoming
it if anything even worse than New York
I mean New York still sort of okay and
in quite a lot of ways it's just I have
a tremendous nostalgia for how it was 20
or 30 years ago so what about for a
Linda what is what what draws you there
Berlin I feel free you know I feel like
I'm treated like an adult I can pretty
much do whatever I want much less
crowded less expensive and just
generally you know a good quality of
life what are you working on now or what
can we what can we promote I'm doing
Duke Ellington with no horns and
completely new arrangements and making
it sound nothing like it did you know
originally what is the appeal of that of
taking I mean somebody who is very much
in the musical firmament and
transforming him into something new
it's something I've always loved to do
is to I mean I've always done this
myself with my own songs over the years
completely rearranged in different ways
because it keeps it fresh it keeps
interesting I think the element of
surprise is really a nice thing to have
I mean how many shows you go to where
you get a surprise somewhere along the
line and I've always tried to have the
element an Ellen to did the same thing
you know for 50 years he reinvented his
own work over and over again so it's in
a way of applying Ellington's methods to
Ellington but you know using sounds and
rhythms and so on that he didn't live
long enough to even think about I want
to thank you Joe Jackson for talking to
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you